Part of spiritual development is to
recognize the satanic tendencies that
characterize you and to fully wrestle
with them and to and to integrate them.
That's the thing.
It's not so much to cast them away,
it's to transmute them,
you know,
and you can see the difference between
people who've done that and people who
haven't,
at least to some degree because people
who haven't integrated the shadow at all
are naive and you can tell that when you
look at them and you can tell that when
you talk to them and because they're
naive,
they're often resentful as well because
they get taken advantage of it and
someone who's integrated that more,
they're dangerous in the martial arts
sort of way,
which is they're dangerous,
but they don't have to be.
They don't have to use it because their
presence radiates.
What would you say it?
It doesn't radiate threat.
Exactly.
Well certainly strength,
but it's.
It's,
it's,
it's the potential for havoc.
That's the right way of thinking about
it.
There's a,
there's an implicit potential for havoc
and that's really necessary.
It,
it.
One of the things that gives people self
respect,
this is an interesting thing about the
integration of the shadow because
recognizing yourself as the locus of
evil,
let's say actually in some sense gives
you far more respect for yourself
strangely enough because the same
respect that you might have for a wild
animal or even a monster.
It's like in those so then maybe you
learn to treat yourself differently like
I think this is particularly true with
regards to the discipline of children.
You know,
if you know that you're a monster and
that that will manifest itself in your
life consciously or unconsciously and
unconsciously,
it's,
it's not good,
then you become better at disciplining
children and the reason for that is that
you don't want to expose them to your
dark side.
And so if they behave and don't provoke
you,
which means they'll also behave for
other people,
then you don't.
The monstrous part can stay in abeyance
and then that's great,
but if you don't understand yourself as
capable of wreaking havoc,
and that can be the kind of havoc that
unfolds over decades,
right?
Because if you're going to abuse a
child,
it's the primitive form of abuse,
the physical abuse,
the sophisticated form of abuse is the
continual undermining of the child's
courage across perhaps their entire life
and that there's a terribly monstrous
element to that,
and if you're not respected properly by
the child,
say you will absolutely take revenge on
them and you know that's a whole in some
sense,
that's the whole Freudian psychoanalytic
story.
It's just not all of it,
but it's a huge part of it.
So interesting that you say that you
have to the fact that you're dangerous
or become dangerous.
Because I'd also say that if you haven't
done that kind of shadow work,
if you haven't made friends with your
anger,
if you haven't integrated it,
you're actually more dangerous because
then things will happen that will.
It will come out in a way that you don't
to.
Right.
It comes out disintegrated.
So it comes out as an autonomous spirit,
right?
Under no one's control and that's like a
burst of rage.
Let's say.
You know,
when you,
when you hear about a mother who's done
something terrible to one of her
children,
it's,
that's the reason is that,
you know,
she,
maybe she's just been laid off.
Maybe she went out and had too much to
drink.
Maybe she's hung over,
you know,
she's,
she's angry and lonesome and she's
overwhelmed by the responsibility of the
children and she has a child who's
testing and she doesn't know how to
limit it.
And one day the child tests at exactly
the wrong time and it's like mayhem and
everybody goes,
well,
what happened?
It's like,
well,
seven terrible things came together at
the same time and produced this outburst
of disintegrated rage and like,
look the hell out when that happens.
You know?
So yeah,
you want to have that.
You either you either have that or it
has you.
Those are the options and you don't
become safe by being castrated.